LeLeur politique du vendredi a
sosonné, nos fidèles
cocollaborateurs sont présents,
MaMadeleine Blais-Morin et
SéSébastien Bovet, bonsoir.
MaMadeleine pas de difficultés à
gégérer le décalage horaire aprs
vovotre périple européen. Merci
d'd'être là. On va donc abordere
papanel avec l'élément le plus
rérécent sur le front politique,
lele drapeau. Le drapeau de
l'l'unifolié qui sera de nouveax
icici dimanche soir, évidemment,
dadans cette optique de
réréconciliation avec l'approche
dudu jour du souvenir la pressin
ététait forte sur Ottawa et le
gogouvernement Trudeau.
- - La pression était forte qui
avavait l'échéance du 11 novembe
asassez rapidement, et les
vévétérans, les anciens
cocombattants ont l'habitude et
c'c'est une tradition qui est
imimportante, devoir le drapeau
mimis en berne pour souligner ls
sosoldats qui sont morts au
cocombat, dans les grandes
guguerres, mais plusus récemment
auaussi, et avec l'année qu'on a
eueue, avec le rapatriement, un
pepeu en catastrophe de canadien
dede l'Afghanistan, avec la
l'l'Afghanistan qui est tombé ax
mamains des talibans, ça été une
anannée difficile pour les ancis
cocombattants, il y en a eu 20 0
enenviron qui ont servi en
AfAfghanistan, donc c'était une
anannée particulière en plus à
cacause de sa, et le gouvernemet
àà trouver une voie de passage,
esest-ce que tous les autochtons
vovont être content, est-ce que
totoutes les organisations des
PrPremières Nations vont être
sasatisfait de cet arrangement,
prprobablement pas. Les
auautochtones, ne sont pas un
grgroupe uniforme, ils n'ont pas
vévécu nécessairement les
évévénements, et découverte des
cocorps des enfants autochtones
susur les sites des pensionnats
auautochtones de la même façon
papartout et c'est normal. Je ni
papas vu non plus de grand tollà
lala suite de l'annonce du
gogouvernement Trudeau, il y a u
énénormémément de consultation u
cocours des dernières semaines
dederniers mois. Donc probablemt
quque le gouvernement à trouver
unune voie de passage. Un mot pr
vovous dire que les Premières
NaNations ont aussi participé au
cocombat canadien, il y a parmi
leles Premières Nations des
ananciens combattants, des
vévétérans, donc pour eux aussi,
çaça peut être important, cette
mimise en berne du temple
cacanadien.
- - Le gouvernement a bien faite
didiscuter avec les nations
auautochtones, avec les peuples
auautochtones parce qu'il fallat
trtrouver une voie de passage et
dede compromis. Ce qui a une
dédécision à courte vue pour
JuJustin Trudeau au mois de mai
dedernier de placer le drapeau n
beberne, on a tous été choqués r
lala découverte des tombes
ananonymes dans les pensionnats,
c'c'est un symbole extrêmement
fofort, mais de dire qu'il allat
icici le drapeau seulement qu'ee
réréconciliation qui serait
susurvenue, c'est ce que la
réréconciliation, des avancées
mamajeures, se prépara en cinq
momois, qu'on arriverait à un
momoment donné à l'échéance du 1
nonovembre et qu'on avait une
ququestion à se poser pour nos
ananciens combattants. Ça aurait
étété très mal vu que les ancies
cocombattants ne puissent pas
avavoir pour le drapeau en bern,
dodont une décision avec un
sysymbole fort au moins 2000 avc
dedes conséquences un peu aussi
papar la suite, ce qui serait
imimportant d'ouvrir la discussn
avavec les nations autochtones
popour trouver un compromis.
- - C'est donc une voie mitoyene
trtrouve Ottawa après, on n'a ps
dedemande ici, partout, aux abos
dedes édifices fédéraux, le
drdrapeau orange de la
réréconciliation, comme l'avaiet
dedemandé certains autochtones.
- - Notamment RoseAnne Archibald
dedemandait que le drapeau orane
popour les pensionnats autochtos
susurtout les édifices fédéraux,
mamais tant et aussi longtemps
ququ'on n'aurait pas retrouvé ts
leles corps des autochtones
rarapatriés chez eux de façon
sysymbolique ou physique. Ça pet
prprendre des années, ce que ça
dédémontre aussi, c'est que le
leleadership de l'assemblée des
PrPremières Nations n'est pas le
mmême qu'il était chez son
prprédécesseur. On avait
auauparavant leadership qui état
unun leader chef de compromis
sosouper et Bellegarde, mais en
mmême tempsps, on avait pas conu
leles derniers mois qu'on a cons
avavec le deuil national
prpratiquement avec la découvere
dedes corps des enfants
auautochtones sur le site des
pepensionnats indiens. Donc voy-
vovous, on est dans une dynamiqe
paparticulière, il semble qu'ily
aiait une voie de passage, et
c'c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
quque là, les drapeaux vont être
hihissés à nouveau et de façon
pepermanente, on est en train de
sese demander? Est-ce que c'est
seseulement le 11 novembre?
QuQu'est-ce va faire le 6
dédécembre, lorsqu'on rappelle e
drdrame de polytechnique et
lolorsque parfois des personnags
imimportants meurent, on met le
drdrapeau en berne, il y a toutn
prprotocole là-dedans, il semble
ququ'il y a une solution
pepermanente qui soit trouvée,
enencore une fois que j'enrage
bebeaucoup, mais avec le drapeau
ququ'on doit ici en quelque part
susur la colline parlementaire,n
nene sait pas encore exactement
ouoù, ça reste quand même rappe,
paparce que chez les Premières
NaNations, il y a une certaine
crcrainte qu'on subisse une crie
coconvives une crise
cocollectivement et qu'on oubli.
JeJe me souviens d'avoir couvert
lolorsque je suis arrivé à Ottaa
LaLa Crise à Attawapiskat, la
crcrise du logement, c'était une
crcrise nationale à l'époque, on
ououblie, c'est facile de
reretourner à nos anciennes façs
dede faire, de dire tout est be,
ququ'on ne vit pas dans les
cocommunautés autochtones, qu'on
n'n'est pas en train d'aller
chchercher de l'eau ailleurs pae
ququ'on n'est pas capable
dede voir l'eau du robinet, quad
onon ne les vit pas les drame
inintergénérationnel, c'est pasn
ououbli, alors il y aura drapeau
d'd'ici quelques par procédure :
ilil faut que cet écart entre ls
auautochtones et les noms
auautochtones, cette
réréconciliation, il faut qu'ele
aiait lieu.
- - Un devoir de mémoire
esessentielle, Madeleine, parlos
mamaintenant d'un autre dossier
dodont on ne peut pas faire
ababstraction, l'une linguiste u
papatron d'Air Canada dénoncée e
papartout, Justin Trudeau lui a
mimis son grain de sel
auaujourd'hui, on apprit que M.
LeLegault, son bureau avait avei
leles gens d'Air Canada, attentn
àà ce que vous allez faire si
vovous maintenez le cap.
- - C'est rare que quelqu'un fae
l'l'unanimité dans les cercles
popolitiques au Québec et au pa,
mamais M. Rousseau a fait
l'l'unanimité de la classe
popolitique générale et
prprovinciale, donc c'est un
exexploit en partant. C'est come
sisi cette controverse ne veut s
s's'en aller, ne veut pas aller
sosous le radar. Aujourd'hui, oa
apappris que le bureau de Françs
LeLegault est intervenu pour
esessayer de convaincre M.
RoRousseau de prononcer des mots
enen français devant la chambree
cocommerce de Montréal, a été
acaccueilli par un merci, mais n
memerci, semble-t-il. Justin
TrTrudeau trouve ça inexplicabl.
IlIl s'en remet à sa ministre ds
lalangues officielles pour la
chchute des choses tout ce qu'il
vava faire, mais la balle rebont
dadans le camp du conseil
d'd'administration d'Air Canada,
popour savoir s'ils vont faire
ququelque chose, est-ce qu'ils
vovont sévir, sanctionner, prene
dedes engagements à l'endroit de
M.M. Rousseau parce que ces
adadministrateurs sont finalemet
leles patrons de M. Rousseau.
OnOn signale qu'il y a 12 membrs
auau conseil d'administration, l
y y en a trois qui vient du
QuQuébec, dont M. Rousseau, deux
auautres de Montréal. À part ça,
ilil y a des gens de la
CaCalifornie, de la Nouvelle-
ZéZélande, le Royaume-Uni, de
l'l'Ontario de l'Alberta, est-ce
ququ'ils vont être sensibilisé à
cecela? Peut-être pas, mais ilse
sosont pas capables de lire les
jojournaux et de voir qu'il y a
unune tempête Québec.
- - Il ne se complique compliqué
lala tâche auprès du gouvernemet
lele fédéral, quand on demande s
fofonds pour sortir de la
papandémie, mieux vaut avoir une
bobonne relation avec le
gogouvernement fédéral et une
gogouvernement fédéral, ce travl
sisi on a un bonne relation avec
lele public. Ça été une de
rerelations publiques que ce qui
s's'est passé cette semaine, ce
ququi vient compliquer le lobbyg
lolorsqu'on cherche à avoir des
fafaveurs.
- - Synopsis apprendre puisqu'un
enengagement à améliorer son
frfrançais, vous avez noté dans
soson communiqué, dire : je
m'm'engage à améliorer mon
frfrançais, on comprend qu'il pt
dede loin, et de l'améliorer, ce
nene sera pas si difficile que ,
mamais pourquoi ne prendrait-il
papas l'engagement d'apprendre e
frfrançais, de suivre des cours,
popourquoi pas de s'engager à
prprononcer un discours à un
momoment donné devant la chambre
dede commerce ou n'importe quele
auautre chambre de commerce avec
dudu français dedans.
- - Je pense que toute cette
afaffaire n'aurait pas créé un i
grgrand tollé si Air Canada
n'n'avait pas la réputation d'êe
lele mauvais élève en termes de
frfrançais. On a vu les plaintes
sese multiplier au cours des 50
dedernières années auprès du
cocommissaire aux langues
ofofficielles qui avaient de la
didifficulté à se demander : mas
cocomment on va faire en sorte e
ququ'Air Canada devienne un bon
jojoueur, se préoccupe sincèremt
dede la langue française du
bibilinguisme national. Air Cana
rérépondait à cela que vu le
nonombre de passagers qui
emempruntent le transporteur,
c'c'est normal que quelques
didizaines aussi quelques
cecentaines de plaintes, c'était
leleur façon de répondre à cela.
MaMais en même temps, il y a une
réréputation qui s'est forgée
anannée après année, commissaire
apaprès commissaire, et là, la
nonouvelle mouture de la loi sur
leles langues officielles vise à
dodonner plus de pouvoir au
cocommissaire aux langues
ofofficielles, entre autres pour
popouvoir avoir plus de mordant
lolorsqu'ils essaient de mettreu
popoint des compagnies ou des
ininstitutions qui ne se
coconformera pas à la loi.
- - Mme Petitpas Taylor faire un
susuivi sur ce dossier, Justin
TrTrudeau semble être très heurx
dede la chance. Petit tour
d'd'horizon rapide, comme 26 de.
TrTrudeau et Legault ont vu leur
paparticipation à tout cela,
cocommençons par Sébastien,
cocomment évaluez-vous la
peperformance de François Legaut
àà Glasgow?
- - François Legault à plusieurs
cocostumes qu'il porte selon le
momoment, elle a été capitaine
QuQuébec pour défendre l'identié
ququébécoise, et la c'était
FrFrançois Legault commis-
vovoyageur, vendeur du Québec,
dédémarcheur en chef du Québec,
ququi voulait vendre
l'l'électricité, le Québec comme
babatterie de l'Amérique du Nor,
c'c'est un peu son slogan.
IrIronique parce qu'il s'est fat
memettre en attendant les rois e
lala décision du Maine de refusr
unun projet d'Hydro-Québec, on
veverra aux allumettes par la
susuite que lui une contestation
totout ça. Ça démontre la
didifficulté que peut avoir
FrFrançois Legault à vendre son
grgrand projet, de faire du Quéc
lala batterie nord-américaine.
CeCela étend dit, il veut vendre
lele Québec, il veut investir ds
l'l'énergie verte, dans
l'l'électrification des
trtransports, mais il n'est pas
dadans les grands discours de
réréduire à 1 1/2° Celsius
l'l'augmentation des températurs
àà travers le monde, dans les
grgrands discours de réduire
enencore plus les gaz à effet de
seserre, il maintient ses cibles
ququi sont plus faibles que les
cicibles du Canada. Il est plusu
raras des pâquerettes à vouloir
fafaire des investissements dans
leles technologies vertes plutôt
quque dans les grands discours.
C'C'est par un pays, Québec, doc
c'c'est peut-être ça, mais ça ft
trtrait faire quand M. Legault
prprend la parole dans ce genre
d'd'événements.
- - M. Trudeau et Guilbault, qun
pepensez-vous?
- - Je mettrai un avis de Scottà
JuJustin Trudeau, toujours là pr
aiaider, donc on fait notre par,
onon veut faire preuve de
leleadership. La réputation du
CaCanada était à refaire d'une
cecertaine façon, lorsque Justin
TrTrudeau est arrivé au pouvoir,
ilil a dit : le Canada est de
reretour. Le Canada est de reto,
çaça voulait par exemple dire qe
lele Canada oeuvre de retour das
l'l'émission de mêmeme que le Ca
veveut un siège au conseil de
sésécurité de l'ONU, et là-dess,
lele bilan est plutôt mince, mas
ilil reste quand même la questin
dedes changements climatiques et
lele Canada n'est pas parvenu
enencore à réduire ses cibles,
mamais il a des mesures a montr,
enentre autres la taxe sur le
cacarbone, entre autres des
prpromesses électorales au
dédéplafonnement, ça été dit, je
pepense que ça été en partie
reremarquée, mais l'épreuve rese
enencore à faire.
- - Qu'est-ce que vous surveillz
lala semaine prochaine?
- - Conférence annuelle du
cocommissaire de l'UPAC la semae
prprochaine, beaucoup de questis
àà lui poser.
- - Focus Cyberlundi, n'y en a s
eueu encore depuis les élection,
j'j'ai l'impression qu'il y a ds